the US says it will unveil its toughest
and most aggressive sanctions ever
against North Korea this could dampen
hopes the two sides will meet at the
Winter Olympics vice president Mike
Pence discussed the sanctions this
morning without saying what they will be
he spoke in Tokyo after meeting with
japan's Prime Minister also this morning
Kim jong-un's sister who is also a key
adviser was added to North Korea's
official Olympic delegation that will go
to South Korea Ben Tracy is at the
Winter Olympic site in Pyeongchang Ben
good morning good morning vice president
pence arrives here on Friday for the
opening ceremony of the Winter Games and
just two days ago he said that a meeting
with North Korean officials here might
be possible but that seems a lot less
likely now after his tough talk in Tokyo
we will not allow North Korean
propaganda to hijack the message and
imagery of the Olympic Games while
announcing a new round of sanctions vice
president pence did not leave much room
for Olympic diplomacy with North Korea
North Korea is the most tyrannical and
oppressive regime on the planet just
before pen spoke North Korea announced
it was sending Kim Jong Un's younger
sister kim yo-jong to the games in south
korea the first person from the ruling
family to cross the border she's
believed to be trusted by her brother
and occupies a high-ranking role in the
regime's propaganda department sending
her could be a sign of Kim jong-un
seriousness about improving relations
but she may not receive a warm welcome
on Tuesday protesters greeted a group of
140 North Korean performers when they
arrived in South Korea you know their
sign showing the crossed out face of kim
jeong-hoon
South Korea has tried to reduce tensions
ahead of the Olympics getting the u.s.
to agree to delay their joint military
exercises and allowing North Korea's
flag to fly at Olympic venues the
insults are also flying again with North
Korean state media calling President
Trump a lunatic and warning that America
will quote go to hell if it attacks
North Korea Jon deloria's an expert in
Korean relations the key is you have to
get the United States in the room with
North Korea so that they can figure out
what are some positive steps that can be
taken in the absence of that the Olympic
sends and we're back to fire and fury
North Korea is planning to stage a
military parade in its capital tomorrow
but US officials say there are
indications that they're not going to
parade their missiles and that might be
a small gesture to South Korea on the
eve of these Winter Games Gale all right
Ben Tracy reporting from South Korea
thank you